they're not afraid to rub people wrong
they're not afraid to piss people off
they're not afraid to fail they're going
to go down and a ball of flames are
going to do it their way
but man
if it works watch out
if you're not pissing someone off you're
not being heard sure what's the logic
behind that
well i think um
i think that
as as artists
i think we're all looking for our voice
i think we're all looking
to
to turn heads and if you kind of just
fall into the norm and you just kind of
do what everybody thinks you should do
you're not going to you're not going to
get the attention you deserve you know
you think about the films that have
truly been game changers or the songs or
the
other works of art
it's because people were weren't afraid
to
think outside of the box or think left
of left
and and
change scares people we talked earlier
about fear especially with the
executives in this industry and um i
just think that
you know
if
we're coming off of a time
where there's been so much hatred passed
back and forth especially on social
media between different sides of the
fence right and at the end of the day
we're all humans we need to we need to
unite
but
what what is apparent is
if you just follow
like sheep and just kind of go about
your merry way you're just you're gonna
you're gonna fit nicely into a mold and
they're going to compartmentalize you
and i think some of the artists that
i've respected most
um
they're not afraid of pissing people off
and making change and making success
come their way because they weren't
afraid to to rub people the wrong way
they weren't afraid to give somebody the
big fu
and say i'm doing it this way
and i don't need your money i don't need
your distribution we're just gonna go do
it i mean you know robert rodriguez is a
classic example dennis hopper you know
when him and peter fonda went out and
did easy rider
some of the people that i admire as
filmmakers i mean you know looking at
somebody
like hal needham um
who you know
came from a tough stuntman background
and and understood the workings of how
to make a movie you know breaking them
down from shot to shot to working with
the editors the producers the directors
the actors the stuntmen and finally just
woke up one day and started making these
great movies
and you know i'm inspired most by rebels
i'm inspired most by people that
weren't afraid if people were going to
approve doesn't mean you're going to be
successful
but
you know
i think
i think there's certain things as
artists that that we have a
responsibility to do i mean art is what
changes the world movies
movies
hollywood songs they
they set the tone for a culture they
change trends you know like that
and
that's
exciting to me
and you know when you hear me say if
you're not pissing people off you're not
being heard well if you're just falling
into what everybody else is doing you're
just falling into what everybody else is
doing you know quentin tarantino became
who he was because he did things his way
he he was willing to roll the dice and
fortunately found people that were
willing to roll the dice with him you
know robert rodriguez mike figgis we
talked about him earlier
um dennis hopper al needham i mean some
of these great filmmakers that just
they're not afraid to rub people wrong
they're not afraid to piss people off
they're not afraid to fail they're going
to go down and a ball of flames are
going to do it their way
but man
if it works watch out
and that just is kind of that mindset
so maybe it doesn't mean deliberately
trying to piss people off but
but knowing that they're going to be
people that are going to be offended or
a
they themselves feel they can't do that
so they don't want you
to do it because absolutely their social
structure wouldn't approve them oh
absolutely i mean i can't tell you how
many times
i would get calls
from people that i had produced with in
the past
that
would say to me you know
i'm really concerned that
this investor may go on imdb and see
some of the things you've done in the
past whether it was with zalman king
or charlie sheen or whatever and i'm
like yeah okay so what's the problem
you know they've had a pretty good run
and you know it's this fear and of you
know maybe
certain people would be nervous or
whatever and i i never understood that i
i would always ask him to please explain
that to me
you know charlie somebody i was very
proud of having a history with
uh in my career and is very instrumental
in getting me to where i am in my life
and
for somebody to come along and and be
nervous about the rebellion of of a
charlie sheen or a bad boy
and and somebody who who made some of
the most incredible erotic cinemas
almond king
and you know those are people that
basically gave people the middle finger
and did what they wanted to do i mean
one of my favorites almond king stories
and we didn't talk about this before we
talked about suits and artists
was i remember working with zalman on a
film
and an executive from the studio was
there we were on the other side of the
world we were in bali indonesia and
there was somebody there telling him how
something had to be done and he oh
absolutely it went through this whole
dog and pony show that was so unsolvent
at the time and the guy left he just
turned around and goes him he goes
watch how we do this and he's got to
remember something he goes if you're
going to if you're going to do something
you do it your way you just got to learn
how to tap dance and tell people what
they want to hear so they give you the
opportunity to do it because remember if
you screw up you're done
but if you're successful
they'll take the credit for it but
you'll work again
and you know that's that's kind of it i
just you know
i i just i went through a phase where
i was getting calls from a lot of
i don't know more prim and proper
entities that
weren't much into
the mentality of just going out and
doing what you want to do everything was
very structured everything was very
formulaic which is not something that i
fall well into
and
i just found that there was a lot of
things that they were trying to
to reshape
or curb or
you know kind of
protect from certain people they were
involved with knowing it's like well you
know there is something called the
internet it's all out there you know
but my point is is that i learned really
quickly that there there are a lot of
people that as you said it's fear they
they're afraid of being looked at as a
rebel or somebody who likes to kick the
dirt or whatever and i i personally
don't don't care i personally don't care
you know do what you want
do what you love love what you do and
and do what feels right in here as long
as you're not hurting anybody
and if it pisses people off say the
video well good i'm glad i got some free
rent in your head
you think people are scared of that
personality type because it can't be
controlled
i i think there's
i you know i think it's not about
trying to be rebellious or being
controlled i think yeah there's a lot of
people that want to try to conform you
especially as artists into what they
want you to be or what their end game is
um i think a lot of there's so many
intricate parts in filmmaking you know
there are people that bridge the money
together with the product and then the
product with the artist and the artists
with the output and there's so many
people that have to be kept happy and
again it goes back to i think executives
and artists being able to
learn how to communicate better better
lines of communication and understanding
each other better
but i think that
there is a lot of fear and and we've
been fortunate in working with people in
in our circle that the decision makers
that come at our end who are the ones
writing our checks
they they love what we do they get what
we do and they trust us and
they say we're doing this because we
believe in you we're doing this because
we like what you do and what you
represent so go do it and and that's it
doesn't matter if they're giving you
five dollars for a film or five million
for a film it's just about
working with people who understand you
and if if you're a true artist and there
are things that you want to
express there's things that you want to
experiment with
i think you need to
respect yourself enough to do that i'm
all for doing work to get paid you know
that we've all been works for hire
things that we wouldn't put on our
resume or maybe things that we're not
excited about there's nothing wrong go
work every time you work you're going to
learn every time you get another credit
you know you'll put some groceries away
in the in the cupboards and you get to
eat and it's fun you get to pay rent and
all that fun stuff but
i think you also have to remember to
allow yourself that freedom and to be
able to do that and i think yeah there's
a lot of people that are afraid i know i
was working with somebody in the past
that was
working with some entities that were not
exciting to me and there was there was a
concern about
what i represented as a filmmaker what
my attitude is and making the films that
i want to make and
where they were thriving and other
networks and other outlets that were
like oil and water and i finally got to
the point i was like you got to pick a
side you know you're either going to
you're going to do what i do or you're
gonna keep doing that which no
disrespect that's that's cool pays your
bills but if you're gonna come here
you're not gonna stifle what i do
hoping that these other entities are not
offended because you're affiliated with
me i don't embarrass anybody i'm not
gonna
you know kill puppies or beat children
but there is certain types of
mentalities mindsets and content that we
make that may not fit
on the family channel and that's just
not kind of content i want to make
so
yeah i think there's a lot of people who
try to stifle and try to conform artists
into being what they want them to be
for the wrong reasons and that's that's
to me is you know that could be very
dangerous for the artist
did you watch the queen's gambit
i actually did
i was afraid you're gonna ask me if i
saw something which i didn't see oh okay
thank you thank you for not asking
myself richardson okay sure so so
forgive me i'm blanking on the
character's name but thomas brodie
sanctu sangster if i i hope i'm saying
his name right so the one that's like
this rebel chess player who kind of
saunters him he's kind of the james dean
right he's the genius yeah and then once
you finally get to know him he's
actually a sweetheart
but he has this mystique and this
persona of this bad boy chess player
amongst some very cookie cutter
intellectual overthinking
you know stanford graduates right
exactly smart people smart people but
but also very invested in their
identities as smart people yeah and so
this guy comes in and he's just like
this
you don't know what to make of them
you're fascinated by them but anyway so
i just it kind of reminds me of that i
just that's a great analogy it was a
great show we really enjoyed that i
think like the rest of the world we
caught that during covet we didn't buy a
chess set afterward um but
uh yeah and you know i think there are
ways and i hate to keep bringing them up
and and i owe so much of my career to
zollman zalman king if you don't know
who he is look him up
um
zolman took me under his wing you know
25 years ago
and
i learned more from my my years with
zalman than anybody and zalman was a
true rebel i mean he was a golden globe
nominated actor turned writer who wrote
you know nine and a half weeks with his
wife
and
and went on to direct some of the most
incredible incredible cinema
um
and nobody told a story through a lens
like solomon nobody could
and
the careers he launched and discovered
are endless whether you talk about
mickey rourke or kim bassinger or you
know david david duchovny and uh just
the list goes on and on and on and my
point is solomon had a relationship his
partner
was it was a man who i still very close
to by the name of david saunders david
david was running
one of the the sub studios under sony
when peter gruber was there and zalman
and this suit
became friends
and they wound up
creating red shoe diaries and launching
show timing that was really their first
series
and built an empire on this this
incredible series starring a guy that
nobody knew about called david duchovny
that you know just opened the letters
and read them and read them to his dog
usually and made these incredible women
empowering erotic cinnamon
the relationship that i most admired of
all the relationships i've known in
hollywood was solomon and david
and just talk about mutt and jeff
you know apples and fork trucks young
and yang
and boy were they were they
that's the kind of relationship
executives and and artists should have
because they they conquered the world i
mean you may not like what they did but
they conquered the world
yeah i think each needs each other
because because one is going to have one
skill set that the other doesn't have
and vice versa and absolutely one will
be organized one will be sort of a
beautiful world be very unorganized yeah
and they need each other
and they really they really
fed off of one another and there was
nobody better in the room they would
fight like cats and dogs i remember you
know david duchovny said when zolman
passed it he was a true artist he'd
think more about the curtains in the
room and the color and the sheen they
would give off off a certain light at
the certain time of day he would shoot
zomling focus on that for hours and then
you know want something painted a
certain color and dave would come in and
say whoa whoa whoa back up how much
money are you spending on painting these
things you know how much you spending on
this fabrics element well well that's
that's insane you can't do it they'd
fight well then ethan i'm not doing a
movie david look at me sorry shane
movies canceled have a good life you
know and i i just slowly go for a walk i
knew they'd fix it and they always did
they did that you know almost every day
but they were an incredible dual duo and
that's the kind of relationship that i i
wish for artists to have with somebody
because they they really david was the
business and zollman was the artist and
boy did they just they were amazing
you